bring in cinema Kosovo she's monitoring
developments for us from Istanbul and
I'm first on the death and injury toll
as it stands right now after the two
powerful earthquakes
yes the second earthquake was as strong
as the first one they're in and some of
the people say it was they felt it much
stronger than the previous one
especially the in the cities like
Malaysia which is closer to the second
epicenter of El Vista and they are
saying that they felt it much stronger
we're talking about the vast geography
here during we're talking about 10
cities 10 Eastern cities some of them
are in decent size and we're talking
about at least 10 million maybe more
than 12 million people who are living in
these cities in these areas so this is a
tough task for the Turkish authorities
and the local rescue workers to deal
with as millions are outside Millions
have been tested with these two
earthquakes and the aftershocks that
counts more than a hundred during the
day after the first after the first
Shake in the morning so
some of the places we are hearing that
the rescue workers haven't even been
able to reach out to those places but uh
Karma Maharaj the epicenter of this
earthquake and gaziantep one of the
biggest Eastern cities that host
millions of people and also that host
the biggest number of Syrian refugees
those cities have been badly affected
and we are hearing that hata is also in
bad condition there are so many
buildings that have been collapsed but
we we don't have many reports according
to hatai antaki region so it is a level
four alarm code for turkey that requires
International assistance and we have
heard Western countries NATO members
including the United States Greece
Georgia Azerbaijan many countries trying
to help turkey sending troops or rescue
workers Medical Aid supplies also just
uh 15 minutes ago we heard from the
Turkish minister a Turkish presidency
that a Russian President Vladimir Putin
called the Turkish president and
conveyed his condolences about the
losses of this earthquake and he
informed Turkish president on how his
country will assist in this search and
rescue operations throughout the week
and in the coming days so International
assistance especially these days are
very important as the first three days
after these earthquakes are critical for
the survivors who are trapped under the
rubbles yeah Cinemas you're saying time
is off the essence and we're looking at
the live picture we were just a moment
ago of the uh the aftermath of that
earthquake destroyed buildings and
presumably we're also hearing that some
airports have been closed some roads
have been damaged so what does this mean
for the for the search and rescue teams
who are trying to get to the most
affected areas what are we learning from
the authorities about that rescue
operation and how it's going
well they're in Turkey is prone to
earthquakes and its history but this
time it is different because first the
the the geography that has been hit by
this earthquake is very vast we're
talking about a huge amount of people uh
about a big population and of course the
biggest challenge is the winter
conditions throughout the last week
trukia has been going through a harsh
winter conditions especially in the
Eastern Anatolian cities these days
these months are very critical because
the snow is heavy even in Istanbul it
has been a difficult weekend we have
been receiving warnings from the
disaster management agency that Tuesday
and Wednesday it will be difficult in
Istanbul because of snow and the wind
and heavy rain since last night flights
have been canceled to these cities
because of the weather conditions and it
was right before the earthquake happened
and after this earthquake as you said
airports are closed in Gaza in
Karma Maharaj and in Adana these are the
cities badly affected by this earthquake
and there is no access and for instance
the highway between hatai and gazantev
has has been totally cracked the people
are not able to access to some of the
district which makes to reach out to
those people for help as a search and
rescue more and more difficult that's
why more Vehicles more carriers actually
are needed as the Turkish president
pointed out in his speech earlier uh in
the day so this is this is a difficult
situation also some infrastructure have
been hit during we know that there are
two hospitals in one in iskandarin and
one in-hat side that have collapsed and
the natural gas pipelines in Gazette
have been also hit and as per the vice
president mentioned this morning it may
take days to repair those pipelines
which means even if people have safe
houses it will be difficult for them to
warm up under these heavy winter
conditions because we saw in the
pictures and we heard from the people
that we know in Gazette and in other
places
when they took out to the streets after
the earthquake it was very cold and it
was very difficult for them to stay
outside some of them went to the public
buildings or some of them went to most
big places that they could warm up and
stay safe so the coming hours are going
to be very difficult for the Turkish
people who have survived this earthquake
and for the rescue workers as it's
becoming dark it is a difficult task and
everybody prays for turkey a neighbor
and friendly countries are trying to
reach out to turkey with medical AIDS
and with more human Source like rescue
workers but more is going to be needed
for this country that has been going
through it's one of its worst
earthquakes in its history thank you so
much synonym for that update from
Istanbul